[Musik]
hallo ich bin's kai timo und ich begrüße
euch herzlich zu dieser neuen folge von
tatort deutschland die crime doku von
bild heute tauchen wir wie versprochen
tief in die kriminellen strukturen der
clans in deutschland und ihre
verbindungen zur musikszene ein dann mal
los
[Musik]
tatort deutschland
die crime doku von bild
[Musik]
das ist nicht mehr kleinkram das muss
viel mehr passieren das sind kleine
kleinkriminellen der kampf gegen die
organisierte kriminalität wird eine
daueraufgabe sein
warum die polizei gemeldet
[Musik]
wir gehen jetzt intensiv an das schreckt
aber nicht ab weiter die geschäfte zu
machen
[Musik]
was also tun gegen die kleinkriminalität
wir beginnen mit den aktuellen
einschätzungen der berliner experten wie
dem security berater michael kuhn und
dem innensenator von berlin andreas
geisel die wir auch schon in der
vorangegangenen folge gehört haben wir
müssen die gesetze verschärft werden und
es müssen ganz knallharter regeln
umgesetzt werden das problem ist so groß
geworden auch die öffentliche
aufmerksamkeit der so groß geworden dass
wir jetzt das große besteck herausfallen
lassen das ist nicht nur nadelstiche
sind die stören sondern das ist
tatsächlich beeindrucken und verhalten
verändern und auch der aktuelle
bezirksbürgermeister von neukölln du
immer ein wenig erschöpft aussieht fügt
hinzu wir sind selbst an deren an dem
punkt wo wir sind waren es über
jahrzehnte lang eine sicherheitspolitik
gegeben hat da hatte sicherlich recht
aber das kind ist in den brunnen
gefallen und nun müssen andere saiten
aufgezogen werden nordrhein westfalen
hat seine politik gegenüber der
organisierten kriminalität und den clans
schon länger angepasst herbert reul der
innenminister von nrw berichtet gelassen
aber nicht ohne stolz wie die aktionen
der polizei derzeit in seinem bundesland
aussehen eine große block sind die
razzien die japaner mal im großen stile
stattfinden aber auch manchmal jede
woche im kleinen stattfinden für die
unterschiedlichen staatlichen
institutionen dafür sorgen dass die
regeln eingehalten werden dass sich
jeder an recht und gesetz hält
also ja
[Musik]
wir haben seit mitte der 80er jahre
diese kleinen entwicklung wir gehen auch
das fahren von 180 familien aus wie die
identifizierten wir haben rund 14.000
straftaten die diesen klar zugeordnet
werden und könnte von 6.000
tatverdächtigen reden die wir bisher
ermittelt haben
am 26 tus legte zwei davon sogar
erfolgreich das ist nicht mehr kleinkram
das sind keine kleinen kriminellen
sondern ist klar
die polizei essen kontrolliert so
regelmäßig die shisha bars wettbüros
diskotheken und clubs der stadt
lennart eichenberg ist gerade im polizei
berlin auf dem weg zum einsatz die alles
ist in der in zusammenhang mit der
bekämpfung der kleinkriminalität
natürlich wichtig er hat ist da wert
darauf und dem da auch weil die
strukturen dieser libanesischen
großfamilien
doch sehr
wichtig uns doch sind
[Musik]
überfallkommando mäßig stürmt die
polizei die war die fast ausschließlich
männlichen gäste versuchen erst gar
nicht zufrieden schnell wird die polizei
fündig
selbständig und halt doch mal mein
kollege los angeles dadurch
unterstrichen
ja keine noch so
dabei
musste
gar nicht gesagt
doch genau wissen was dabei oder
kann ich meinen rechten und pflichten
haben dabei findet
dann haben sie sonst zu haben
[Musik]
ein ganz guter stundenlohn
schnell ist klar dass es sich vermutlich
um drogengeld handelt der essener
polizei präsident frank richter dazu
shisha bar sind nach unseren
erkenntnissen dass sich nicht alle aber
die die wir wirklich im fokus haben
gewinnen können von cannes wo sich
verabredet wieder zu straftaten im
bereich btm das betäubungsmittelgesetz
wir haben festgestellt was ist mit
menschen die dort arbeiten muss weil sie
in der frage schwarzarbeit bis hin zum
sozialdienst mit hoch diese razzien in
bars und clubs passieren im ganzen
stadtgebiet gleichzeitig hundertschaften
der polizei beamte vom zoll der
steuerfahndung und ziviles personal sind
dafür eingesetzt
koordiniert wird das alles von der
führungsgruppe aktionsplan clan in essen
in dem mit menschen und computern
vollgestopften raum befindet sich eine
große karte und baum diagramme mit den
verdächtigen personen hauptkommissar
thomas weise erklärt die karte
abgebildet mit den einzelnen punkten der
pferde das sind gelegt die den letzten
tagen festgestellt das wird auf dieser
karte dokumentiert und ist natürlich
rein visuelle eigentlich schon relativ
einfach zu erkennen wo beschwert
umzusetzen und problembereiche frank
richter polizeipräsident von essen
erklärt dass man anhand der übersicht
schnelle entscheidungen treffen kann
entscheidend ist für uns das haben wir
auch gesagt dieser form von nadelstichen
dass wir pro woche zwischen 1 und 4 1 zu
fahren das ist jene ist verständigt
wohnen ruhig was ihm teilweise ganz erst
eine durchsuchungsmaßnahmen sein ein
bisschen natürlich auch dann schon ganz
großen einsetzen wo wir mehrere hundert
beamte eingesetzt sein
und nebenbei passieren bei den razzien
noch dreister ablenkungsmanöver die aber
von der polizei geduldig mit geahndet
werden wir haben viele
ordnungswidrigkeiten poser verhalten man
muss natürlich auch zwei kunden das geld
verdient in der regel immer fahrzeuge
oberhalb der 100000 euro auge markt das
geld ist diesen groß aber immerhin im
ergebnis zeigt sich die ordnungsmacht
wieder deutlicher als gegenpol zu den
clans wie es der innenminister von nrw
herbert reul nach einer der ersten groß
razzien im jahr 2019 anspricht die
größte aktion dieser art in deutschland
glaube ich bisher gegeben hat das ist
jetzt einfach immer zu demonstrierenden
auch gegenüber der polizei anzuzeigen
damen und herren wir können auch noch
mehr in berlin es schulwesen stimme als
sie noch dann ist fahl und so zu stellen
möchte ich wenig haben neben
unversteuerten tabak produkten drogen
und bargeld heben die behörden auch
verstecke mit hehlerware aus und
beschlagnahmen fahrzeuge und
wertgegenstände nochmal essens
polizeipräsident frank richter zu den
überlegungen der ermittler die frage wo
tut es sie sich ebenfalls sehr schnell
fokussiert auf einen bereich des sudans
geld gibt
[Musik]
was daran meisten weh tut ist dass wir
wohl nicht mehr
[Musik]
unterstützen die polizei justiz gehört
dabei
die geschäfte zu machen und die clans
während sich heftig dagegen werden
aggressiver und versuchen wiederum die
aktionen der polizei zu stören wie der
essener polizeipräsident anmerken muss
[Musik]
bei einsätzen von den clans ist
besprochen stückchen aber auch
körperliche gewalt schlagen und wir
haben eine lehrstelle gehabt in dem
erfolg der maßnahme mit einer weiteren
mitarbeiter zusammengetreten worden sind
in unseren brennpunkten unseren hotspots
ausgesprochen schwierig kleinste
maßnahmen alleine schon durch
[Musik]
grundsätzlich ist die frage der wagen
kam nicht nur ein problem aus dem motto
miss fahren spricht indessen da es gibt
einige spots dass wir berlin und bremen
teilweise in niedersachsen
das stimmt natürlich deshalb erst einmal
zurück nach berlin dort ist man auch
schon seit einiger zeit dabei den
finanzfluss und die geldwäsche der clans
zu behindern security unternehmer
michael kuhr hat sich umgehört
mit einigen klaren gesprochen wie jetzt
eigentlich die grazien so ankommen ob
das abschreckt haben gesagt natürlich
ist das belastend das heißt die
verstecken jetzt ein bisschen besser
ihre einkünfte das hilft aber nicht
immer auch die ermittler sind clever und
nehmen sich wettbüros und spielhallen
vor ideale orte um schwarzes geld rein
zu waschen
bezirksbürgermeister martin hikel ist
über die beschlagnahmungen oft selbst
verwundert wenn unsere gäste geräts
unseren automaten mag man kaum glauben
das sind in der regel oftmals mindestens
fünfstelliger höhe geldbeträge drinnen
waren sie eingeschlossen worden sind und
einfach keine steuern bezahlt worden
sind tut es schon weh wenn das ding
abgelaufen ist dann kann man die ganze
kohle einbehalten und das macht dann
schon unterschied dann plötzlich 23.000
euro oder kassel film mit dem man
kalkuliert hat peanuts meint michael
kuhr
das reicht aber bei weitem nicht aus die
sarrazin es muss viel mehr passieren
dass die auch richtig angst bekommen und
das klappt nur raten regel respekt und
angst haben die natürlich die clans vor
der beweislastumkehr
das ist natürlich fantastisch
und das ganze geld ja ich zitiere da wie
schon in der letzten folge dr stefan
görz dozent im fachbereich bundespolizei
der hochschule des bundes in lübeck
die politischen entscheidungsträger
deutschlands haben das problem
kriminellen familienclans erst relativ
spät erkannt und die behörden waren
lange zeit überfordert da es der
deutschen polizei an personal und
möglichkeiten fehlt um kleinkriminalität
als phänomen bereich der organisierten
kriminalität zu bekämpfen dabei helfen
könnte eine gesetzesänderung aus dem
jahr 2017 seither müssen die behörden
nicht mehr nachweisen dass die
familienclans sie vermögen illegal
erworben haben sondern die clans müssen
belegen auf legalem wege an das geld
gelangt zu sein ich denke diese änderung
hilft sehr wohl ein beispiel aus 2018
zeigt im juli bekam der kriminelle clan
der familie remo in berlin die folgen
dieser gesetzesnovelle zu spüren in
einer jahre lang vorbereiteten aktion
beschlagnahmte die polizei
77 immobilien des clans im wert von neun
millionen euro gegen 16 mitglieder des
clans laufen seite ermittlungen wegen
geldwäsche das ist klotzen und nicht
kleckern
andreas geisel der innensenator von
berlin sieht aber noch mehr
möglichkeiten um die clans bei ihren
geschäften zu stören wir zeigen den
handelnden personen frühzeitig auf dass
sie sich nicht außerhalb der regeln
ungestraft außerhalb der regeln der
gesellschaft bewegen können das heißt
frühzeitiges eingreifen bei
verkehrsverstößen frühzeitiges
eingreifen in den gewerbebetrieben also
auf zeigen es gibt regeln und die regeln
sind einzuhalten und nehmen diese
verstöße nicht annehmen und es gibt noch
das mittel die nur geduldeten clan
mitglieder die nicht über die deutsche
staatsbürgerschaft verfügen abzuschieben
das ist oft schwierig aber manchmal
gelingt es und macht schlagzeilen
spektakulärer schlag gegen die
organisierte kriminalität in deutschland
in einer streng geheimen operation wurde
clan-chef premiere in seiner wohnung in
bremen festgenommen und anschließend in
seiner heimat libanon ausgeflogen der
menüplan auch miri familie genannt ist
die deutsche bezeichnung für einen aus
dem libanon stammenden clan der
volksgruppe der macher lamy der
überwiegend in bremen ansässig ist
andere schwerpunkte seines auftretens
sind essen und berlin der clan ist eng
mit der organisierten kriminalität
verwoben und weist mafiöse strukturen
auf familienmitglieder betreiben
schutzgeld erpressungen drogen und
illegalen medikamentenhandel
waffenhandel oder sind dem
rotlichtmilieu aktiv in bremen werden
etwa 30 familien mit 2600 angehörigen
dem clan zugeordnet
der jugendstadtrat und stellvertretende
bezirksbürgermeister von neukölln falko
liecke begrüßt das zurück führungs
verfahren für mich ist die abschiebung
von herrn idee ein ganz ganz starkes
signal an diese organisierte
kriminalität damit wird klar dass die
behörden übergreifender abstimmung
funktioniert das auch nichts nach außen
dringt im vorfeld die richtig
vorbereiten können und es ist ein
schwerer schlag für diese strukturen was
auch gut so ist ich gehe davon aus dass
er über kurz oder lang auch wieder in
deutschland auftaucht und da ist es
natürlich die einreisebehörden am zuge
dem zu erkennen um dann eine einreise
auch zu verhindern und wenn er es doch
irgendwie schaffen sollte ihm möglichst
entweder aus deutschland aus zu
befördern falko liecke chef
bezirksbürgermeister martin hikel fasst
den stand kurz zusammen in allen ländern
wo es mafiastrukturen geburt
organisierte kriminalität gibt dann
wissen sie auch nicht weg sagt er ist
immer da ich glaube in der gesamtsumme
der verschiedenen maßnahmen das ist ein
wichtiger baustein und wie ich bin
verdeutlicht auch gegenüber den menschen
gegenüber den bürgern dass sie keine
rechtsfreien räume gibt was die
kriminalitätsprävention betrifft hat es
natürlich nur sinn wenn es auch mit
anderen maßnahmen flankiert wird die
organisierte kriminalität wird eine
daueraufgabe sein
security berater michael kuhr sieht er
schwarz und zwar aus der praktischen
sicht eines menschen der nicht dem
ruhigen rathaus sitzt sondern jeden tag
mit seinen kollegen das berliner szene
leben beobachtet
[Musik]
berlin kann im kampf gegen deutschland
kann den kampf hoch nrw den kampf gegen
die organisierte kriminalität mit diesen
nadelstichen absolutes der bilder wir
hatten vor 2015 schon erhebliche
probleme mit der organisierten
kriminalität der kampf war so gut für
beliefern ohren
2050 mit der flüchtlingswelle
das kannst du ja noch vor sich wir
werden wichtige ghettos bekommen und
dann wird uns immer die zehnte noch
begleiten wird kein weg daran vorbei
innensenator andreas geisel ist da eher
pragmatisch auch ihm ist klar wo sich
die politik derzeit noch befindet panik
hilft da nicht und wenn sie mich fragen
ob sie heute nur die spitze des eisbergs
bekämpfen dann antworte ich ihnen das
mag vielleicht seien aber irgendwo
müssen wir beginnen
[Musik]
angefangen mit
chanel bekannte gangsta rapper und mixed
martial arts kämpfer aus berlin schaut
aus dem verdreckten fenster eines
kleinen diner restaurants mal nicht
irgendwo in neukölln sondern in einem
vorort von phoenix arizona united states
mit 16 17
und das ist genau der film den man alle
dann sozusagen hast du musst wo sie
gemerkt haben dass geht und man kriegt
damit
der perfekt trainierte körper spannt das
t-shirt mit dem aufdruck thränhardt weit
über der brust chanel bürgerlich anthony
taylor gilt als wegbereiter des gangsta
rap in deutschland jedoch kommt diese
aussage von ihm selbst
moabit neukölln und wedding war seinen
hut in den 90ern als die hip hop welle
über deutschland herein brach die
bedienung gießt dünnen kaffee nach schon
dadurch dass meine mutter kriminell war
in heroinsüchtige
und eine prostituierte
habe ich schon sehr früh dinge gesehen
und kenne
die nicht wirklich für kinder bestimmt
sind
sie reden nur billige soll es nicht mehr
geben ich rede nicht wenn ich im
künstlich nicht
[Musik]
und wenn chanel spricht lachte viel und
das 0 3 0 tattoo am hals blieb dabei
seit 2008 ist er wieder in den staaten
und gangster ist da ja noch immer
irgendwie er trägt immer eine waffe denn
die gegend hier ist raus herr rapp noch
will aber keinen kommerz und bietet
seine musik meist kostenlos an für mich
hat sich das insofern gelohnt
auszusteigen aus neuester noch wieder
nach hause zu gehen weil ich mich
einfach hier viel besser fühle natürlich
ist es hier viel gefährlicher ich trage
was wir natürlich immer grundsätzlich
bei mir um selber geschützt zu sein aber
natürlich wir tragen ja keine
schreckschusspistolen bei den
geschätzten wenn man fast sagen komm
löcher dann zieht er sein t shirt hoch
niemand im diner beachtet dass unter
zeigt irgendwie belustigt seinen haben
er ist die schlechtere hatte ich mit 11
da sind wir um grad und haben leute
abgezogen und um mich zu beweisen habe
ich natürlich dann auch gebrauchen und
messer gemacht worüber hier absolut
nicht drin aber es gehört ja nun hat
sich mein leben dazu und was soll ich da
sagen manche denken wir dass ein
einschussloch aber dass und
messerstechereien wilson hat jemand
schön sein tief rhein geboren erhält
muss
nun sowas ist alles ganz normal lassen
so kriegst das sind kleine kriegs nahm
was aber führte dazu dass air berlin den
rücken zuwandte und aus der deutschen
rap-szene ausstieg er hatte einen großen
namen und war gut im geschäft 2000 hat
sich die szene so verändert vorher war
alles sehr amerikanisch qualität gewesen
und dann habe ich zu meinem freund
damals gesagt passt mal auf irgendwann
werden die ganzen kann man auf der film
kommt zu retten berlin hat ganz schlau
durch spector eine richtlinie für web
gefunden so wir wollen deutsche
ansprechen mit denen wir wollen [ __ ]
ansprechen mit denen wir wollen die aziz
ansprechen mit denen sido fler er macht
ihr bedingt die deutschen die araber
haben angefangen zu stürmen mit
bushido in der vorherigen folge ging es
schon mal um ihn nur zur erinnerung
bushido geboren am 28 september
1978 in bonn als anis mohamed youssef
ferchichi auch bekannt unter dem
pseudonym sonny black ist ein deutscher
rapper und songwriter dessen stil sich
an den us amerikanischen gangsta rap
anlehnt er arbeitet auch als produzent
und ist inhaber eines plattenlabels die
sagt dem kopf eines ja das handtuch
dafür geschrieben wenn nur ein migrant
bist du willst alaba und dieses ganze
mit toren du willst du nicht mit dem
deutschen rapper zusammen und dann bist
du bezahlt mir geht's gut und du kannst
deine messe fahren und du kannst deine
shisha cafés und du kannst das ganze
geld waschen
ein wenig verbittert scheint chanel bei
aller lässigkeit doch zu sein oder ist
es wut der bushido der zum beispiel
deutschland
aber halt das aussehen von seinem vater
trägt uns auf die schiene zu stellen wir
in den kanadischen umso mehr das kann
allen dingen dann reinkommen ist so ja
ja wisst ihr ihr habt ja nicht so
wirklich eine
zielgruppe
und das fühlt erfüllt da ist der ist mit
uns ja aber von den verkäufen her
ging es mir um meine frage zu machen
wurden ganz schlecht mit durchschnitt
[Musik]
in bushidos strafakte finden sich auch
punkte wie beleidigung
steuerhinterziehung versicherungsbetrug
und körperverletzung erscheint einige
feinde gehabt zu haben und fand es sich
so an arafat abou chaker mit der bitte
um schutz der wurde schnell bester
freund manager und vertraglicher vormund
in einem interview mit der frankfurter
allgemeinen zeitung am 24 juni 2012 sagt
bushido über sich und arafat wir sind
die besten freunde
das geht sogar über den freundschaft
status hinaus ich habe mich nicht auf
irgendwelche leute eingelassen sondern
wir sind zu dem geworden dass wir heute
sind es ging damals nicht um vorteile
über jahre haben wir dann unsere
positionen eingenommen es hat sich
herausgestellt dass wir alle mit dem was
wir können und wer wir sind sehr gut
interagieren so haben alle profitiert
und das nicht nur im finanziellen sinne
ich weiß dass ich daran schuld bin zu
sagen wir mal 60 70 prozent dass busch
wieder zu alter form und ist also den
thron den er da versucht man sich darauf
gesetzt hat dann waren wir ganz kräftig
an segen dran und das muss dann auch
alle nacht gemacht danach
leute so von einmal die kennedys früher
wo er war bum und authentischen
geschichten über ihn erzählen konnten
und das war für ihn ein so mehr ich muss
mich zusammentun die dafür sorgen dass
alle ihre schnauzen halten der punkt ist
er hat das von einer gang in einen
klaren ebene mit reingezogen und da fing
das dann mit arafat und nicht verlassen
vertrag groß muss der wusste es wird eng
der gangster bleibt wurde groß und ein
noch größeres business das brachte
schnell interesse der reichen kleine
szene für die jungen rapper
[Musik]
berlin park am gleisdreieck ben salomo
schaut den gelben u bahnen nach bis auf
das auffällige basecap erinnert seien
dezenter kleidung stil in keiner weise
daran dass auch er eine berliner hip hop
kurve ist dann schulen sagen wir die
lehrer wenn ich hier die kids frage was
heute später werden dann ist die erste
antwort millionär die zweite antwort
rapper und die dritte antwort
instruments und wenn man da macht weiter
nachfragt was sitzen von rapper werden
dann ist die verantwort gangsta rapper
und gangster sein abitur ja natürlich im
knast was sonst ist da nicht authentisch
und würde es nicht akzeptieren wenn
salomo ist der künstlername von jonathan
kálmán owetschkin salomo geboren 1977 in
israel
singer songwriter youtuber und buchautor
der in berlin aufgewachsen ist und die
konzertreihe raab am mittwoch gründete
im november 2016 veröffentlichte er sein
erstes solo album mit dem titel es gibt
nur einen und rapp am mittwoch war eine
wichtige institution für die
hip-hop-szene berlin war da in der
hinsicht ein etwas härteres pflaster
hier herrschte schon sehr früh ein
starker konkurrenzkampf irgendwann als
dann wirklich absehbar wurde dass aus
dieser straßenrap nummer wirklich auch
ein geschäft wurde kam folgendes halt
auch aus rapper die so auf gangster
machen die müssen ja eine große klappe
und diese leute brauchen dann plötzlich
eigentlich eine art schutz
aber man kann halt nicht irgendwie zur
polizei gehen weil man ist der
gangster-rapper wenn das jetzt irgendwie
nur so auf diese musikalischen level
geblieben wäre wäre alles in ordnung ist
ja gut dass die leute dann ihre
rivalität irgendwie mit der kunst wurde
als sport austragen in berlin
insbesondere hat sich das tatsächlich
halt auch mit gewalt ausgedrückt wenn
salomo steht kurz auf streckt sich und
schaut sich um hier und da lungen kleine
grüppchen von jungen männern herum
manche gehen aneinander vorbei und geben
sich kurz die hand vermutlich werden
hier drogen gedealt nichts besonderes in
berlin kreuzberg wenn salomo erkennt den
kriminellen gedanken der clans hinter
der vordergründigen unterstützung der
jungen musiker abgesehen davon herr ist
doch cool die rappen über drogen und so
das ist ja super werden ja dadurch zu
markenbotschaftern für unsere produkte
einfach
kluges perfide kluges geschäftsmodell
leider aber beim braten über drogen ist
es wohl nicht geblieben so wie ich das
beobachtet habe ist die web szene in den
letzten jahren zu einem sammelbecken
geworden für drogensüchtige
kleinkriminelle und die strukturen die
dahinterstehen crypto islamisten
linksextreme verschwörungstheoretiker
aller spektren das ist schon ein
ziemlich toxisches klima weil sich
innerhalb dieser
denkstrukturen auch ideologien breit
machen können die für mich irgendwann
untragbar wurden ja also dieser breite
konsens an akzeptanz für antisemitisches
denken in dieser rap szene wirklich in
weiten teilen sehr ähnlich wie die bei
den rechtsrock nazis und dafür gibt es
einige beispiele wie den islamistischen
extra dennis quaid alias deso dogg der
sich mit seinen texten immer weiter
radikalisiert und am ende 2018 als die s
kämpfer in syrien bei einem
drohnenangriff getötet wurde freilich
erst nachdem er zahlreiche
kriegsverbrechen begangen hatte ich
glaube insgesamt sollte man anfangen zu
hinterfragen ob das positiv ist dass
solche verbrecherischen syndikate
überhaupt mit einer
musikszene in der form verbunden sein
sollte
secure it unternehmer michael kuhr hat
schon einige konzerte der
gangster-rapper miterlebt sein
unternehmen organisiert den einlass und
die sicherheit bei großveranstaltungen
in clubs und events seine meinung zu
musikern die die nähe zu den reichen
kleins suchen ist eindeutig wenn man
sich einmal mit
gangstern mit klassenerhalt
ottawa sind albaner sind türken kohlen
man das nicht einfach mit teufel
webster bushido hat sich von seinem
langjährigen geschäftspartner und besten
freund arafat abou chaker getrennt
jahrelang ließ sich der musiker mit der
arabischen großfamilie ein und anstatt
sich zurückzulehnen man sich
freundschaftlich an ist man hat viel
erlebt aber nein
friedlich das nicht möglich
eine zeit lang sind arafat abou chaker
und bushido wie siamesische zwillinge
aufgetreten gerne legte arafat auch mal
hand an wenn jemand seinem
lieblingskünstler an der bühne zu nahe
kam dann setzte es ohrfeigen
[Applaus]
[Musik]
arafat müsste normalerweise in
verschiedenen dankbar sein er hat durch
millionen von ihnen
es gibt leute die arafat jawala und gott
hier
macht ein label auf und sucht jetzt den
neuen rapstar hab ich gehört
[Musik]
zurück zu chanel in phoenix arizona der
ehemalige berliner gangster-rapper fährt
mit seinem in die jahre gekommenen suv
durch den ziemlich runde gekommenen vor
ort
solches geld bekommt aus dem schönes
leben ich wollte früher immer reichlich
wollte auch
diese ganze besser diese leute stehen
für etwas was ich an davon habe womit
ich eigentlich mein geld machen ist das
hat nicht so sommer gemacht dass immer
wieder zu sehen fallen diese sehen ist
dabei ist ein gangster rapper definitiv
ein ganz oben an der spitze des moschee
und das haben jetzt alle gehabt dass
alle gesehen ich wusste das schon immer
ich mag das nicht wenn man jemandem der
am boden ist definitiv am boden aber ist
die geister die angerufen hat schnell
fährt etwas langsamer einer seiner home
i steigt aus und steckt sich die 9mm
pistole in den hosenbund der berge
schoss dann verhandelt er
augenscheinlich mit einem anderen typen
an der ecke es wirkt nicht besonders
friedlich
[Musik]
wohl eher nicht herkommen da gab es noch
nicht das ding ist man muss immer
vorstellen würde deutschen werken würden
hier rumstehen und erst wenn die
komplett ausgehoben werden
vernehmung nicht erzählen da weiß ich
war damals erschossen heißt
das wenn das war ich selber
der home i steigt wieder ein und grinst
die fahrt geht weiter für mich wäre und
bekommt eine rockerbande oder einer
kleinfamilie struktur mich in einer form
zuzuschreiben weil ich das unsinn
gehalten habe sehr schwach
[Musik]
damit spielt chanel auf den vertrag
zwischen arafat abou chaker und bushido
an der eine komplette vollmacht über den
künstler an den vermuteten klein chef
darstellt
wikipedia im april 2013 wurde bekannt
dass bushido dem anführer des
mafia-clans arafat abou chaker 43
bereits im dezember 2010 eine notariell
beglaubigt die generalvollmacht erteilt
hatte die diesen unter anderem dazu
ermächtigt beliebig über bushidos
gesamtes eigentum sein vermögen und
seine konten zu verfügen sowie
rechtskräftige geschäfte in seinem namen
zu tätigen die vollmacht gilt auch über
bushidos tod hinaus das berliner
landeskriminalamt sieht bushido als
mitglied des mafia clans und die
generalvollmacht als so etwas wie
bushidos adoptions wo kunde für seine
neue familie
tja schritte sieht ähnlichkeiten zu dem
verhältnis einer prostituierten zu ihrem
gewalttätigen zuhälter
arafat habe immer kräftig mitverdient
und bushido sei der ängstliche
schutzbedürftige gewesen beide wurden in
kleinmachnow einer edlen villenviertel
vor den toren berlins auch schnell
nachbarn bushido gehörte zur familie
[Musik]
heute braucht bushido rund um die uhr
polizeischutz personenschützer michael
kohl winkt nur ab und jetzt mühsam aus
rollkoffer wasserkopf auf youtube machen
er steht komplett unter personenschutz
familie kinder alle
belastung und das alles vor den augen
seines ex vormundes arafat der sich im
netz über ihn lustig macht
sich in grund und boden
vielleicht muss er arafat ins gefängnis
vielleicht geht alles auf
aktuell laufen die verfahren gegen den
mutmaßlichen klein chef noch bushido war
es anders er wird nie wieder ruhig
schlafen können und daniel taylor bringt
es auf den punkt und ich habe immer
gesagt wenn die leute erst mal ein
bisschen erwachsener kann sich ein
bisschen mehr mit rap auseinandersetzen
werden sie merken dass jeder der so was
macht einen absolut rossi ist und von
heute auf morgen alles verlieren kann
[Musik]
abdulkadir osman brüllt gern im hof der
falkenhagener straße in berlin-spandau
herum seine rücksicht auf die
miteigentümer des hauses hält sich stark
in grenzen wie kann ich eine nachbarin
feststellt
denn schon der erste unrat und am
fußabtreter zu finden waren die vom
eigentümer rinn hat er uns nur darauf
hingewiesen dass unter uns eine familie
wohnt mit vielen kindern
der überaus kräftig gebaute abdulkadir
osmann ist anfang dreißig vollbart
glatze und er ist auch gern per video
chat im internet unterwegs und teilt
dort am liebsten verbal gegen die
vermeintlich ausländerfeindlichen
mitbewohner aus
das wird noch schön die nächsten jahre
karlisch ist mitte fünfzig schmale
brille kurzes haar sie zeigt beim
erzählen auf einem tablett hunderte
fotos von dokumentierten übergriffen auf
sie und andere nachbarn im haus fast
schon ungerührt berichtet sie von müll
kot urin schmierereien lahm und
beleidigungen tolle eier fliegen an die
fenster autoreifen wurden zerstochen der
hof verwüstet und permanent okkupiert
65 270 fälle drauf die heizungsrohre
klopfen essensresten briefkasten
essensreste vor wohnungstür und andere
diverse schmierereien es war dann auch
gut und das so die tür geschlagen wurde
klaus-dieter hat zusammen mit seiner
frau gegen den nachbarn herrn roßmann
57 anzeigen laufen tendenz steigend
englisch ist mittlerweile experte im
türspion austauschen
später eigentlich gemacht hat
[Musik]
abdulkadir osman jetzt weiter ungerührt
im netz gegen die hausgemeinschaft er
fühlt sich extrem sicher und manchmal
scheint es als habe er rückendeckung
ganz besondere art und als ob alles auf
ein ziel hinausliefe
[Musik]
die wohnung die auswahl die es ja auch
über eine strohfrau erkauft worden und
von ausländischem geld bezahlt worden da
diese clanstrukturen hinter stecken
immer irgendwo ein geldgeber der das
finanziert und in der tat gibt es
ausreichend belege dafür dass eros man
dem berüchtigten remo clan angehört
fotos jedenfalls belegen die nähe
osmanns zum klein chef ist
der bekannte berliner strafverteidiger
und anwalt burkhard benecken vertritt
oft kleinfamilien in seinem schicken
büro mit kunst an der wand wird er mit
dem weniger schicken foto und
videomaterial der nix konfrontiert er
gibt zu das ist natürlich einer der
fälle die ganz klar ein schlechtes licht
auf die arabischen groß sah mit den
werften meines erachtens ist das aber in
dieser form durchaus ein kleinstes sei
nur ein einzelfall das beruhigt eine
freundin der familie nicht nicht
besonders hildegard jagodzinski aber
weiß eines dass sie nicht aufgeben
dürfen inzwischen werden die angst
genommen von der polizei sie kommen aus
sehr schnell aber man merkt eben weil er
sehr genau weiß was er tun kann das ist
strafrechtlich nicht wirklich relevant
ist kann die polizei in der regel nichts
tun und mit jedem eingestellten
verfahren das ist das fatale haben die
wirklich
aber es könnte sehr kalkulierte klare
gründe für das verhalten von abdul kadir
osman geben und am ende würden familien
wie die nicht dem druck nicht
standhalten anwalt burkhard benecken
räumt folgendes ein natürlich gibt es
auch fälle in denen teilweise auch
arabische familien mitglieder versuchen
etwa ein straßenzug für sich zu gewinnen
und es gibt dann auch bedrohungen von
einzelnen eigentümern mit dem ziel dass
sie ausziehen damit man selbst
irgendwann die immobilie erwerben kann
die mieter der falkenhagener sind noch
nicht so weit sie wollen definitiv nicht
ausziehen aber viel hoffnung machen sie
sich trotzdem nicht
etwas ist aber doch in bewegung gekommen
abdul hadi osmann ist verurteilt worden
nein nicht zu gefängnis nach mehreren
jahren belästigungen und über 200 von
nachbarn polizeilich gemeldeten
vorfällen wurde das mehrfach
vorbestrafte clan mitglied im januar
2021 wegen sachbeschädigung und nötigung
zu einer geldstrafe von 200 tagessätzen
als zehn euro verurteilt das sollte ohne
weiteres finanziell für den renault
klaren zu stemmen sein immerhin scheint
es die erfolgreichste kriminellen bande
der neueren zeit zu sein
lisa ja nie die gerichtssprecherin nennt
die namen nicht aber es handelt sich um
angehörige der familie der
stellvertretende bezirksbürgermeister
von neukölln falko liecke präzisiert wir
haben ja eine familie uns am meisten
sorge macht mit 18 straftätern im alter
zwischen 16 und 27 mit über 200
straftaten und das sind nur die taten
die quasi aus ermittelt wurden im netz
kann man alles zum fall nachlesen wenn
man es damals in den medien nicht
mitbekommen hat
in der nacht auf den 27
märz 2017 wurde eine rund 100 kilogramm
schwere bike maple leaf goldmünze aus
der ausstellung des münzkabinetts berlin
gestohlen der materialwert zum
tatzeitpunkt rund 3,8 millionen euro im
juli 2017 wurden vier tatverdächtige
verhaftet gold an haftungen der münze
wurden in einem aus anderen gründen
beschlagnahmten fahrzeug sichergestellt
die münze selbst wurde nicht gefunden
und ist aller wahrscheinlichkeit nach
eingeschmolzen am 20 februar 2020 wurden
wissam und ahmet remo vom landgericht
berlin im münstertal schuldig gesprochen
und jeweils zu viereinhalb jahren haft
verurteilt der ehemalige wachmann dennis
b der zusammen mit ahmed remo in die
schule gegangen war erhielt eine
freiheitsstrafe von drei jahren und vier
monaten das gericht geht von noch
mindestens zwei weiteren tätern aus
dreist ein unwiederbringlicher schaden
bei dem es nicht bleiben wird
innensenator von berlin andreas geisel
vermutet profane gründe hinter dem raum
solche öffentlichen überschaut haben die
große diebstähle oder überfällig das
kadewe oder der diebstahl der goldmünze
oder museum werden nach meiner
interpretationen
begangen aus prestigegründen schaut her
was wir können
[Musik]
geldtransporter am berliner
alexanderplatz überfallen maskierte
täter flüchteten dann mit dem fahrzeug
mussten den gepanzerten wagen allerdings
anschließend zurücklassen auf ihrer
flucht feuerten die täter dann mehrfach
auf die sie verfolgenden polizeibeamten
verletzt
anwalt burkhard benecken möchte zwischen
solchen spektakulären verbrechen keine
konkreten familien bezüge knüpfen wieder
alles einzelfälle in den medien momentan
von der ganz großen kleinkriminalität
gesprochen und es wird aus meiner sicht
sehr einseitig über arabische
großfamilien gesprochen es tauchten
immer wieder die gleichen namen auf
angefangen vom publisher kann überall
sein bis hin zu ali khan und um heirat
der besondere reiz warum ich zahlreiche
großfamilie und vertrete ich darin dass
sie meines erachtens in wesentlichen
teilen in der öffentlichen diskussion
diskriminiert werden und ich war schon
immer für gerechtigkeit und dafür
personen die in die ecke gedrängt werden
den beizustehen und trotz all dem
öffentlichen druck zu sagen bitte gibt
diese menschen in einem rechtsstaat auch
ein faires verfahren und lasst es mit
diesen vorurteilen nach dem motto alle
sind gleich alles in kriminelle das ist
für mich eine ganz besondere aufgabe die
ich auch in einem rechtsstaat
ok clans finden andere sachen wertvoll
und nehmen sie sich im märz 2021 wurde
ein mitglied des remo clans festgenommen
das mitglied steht im verdacht an einem
bewaffneten raubüberfall bei dem im
februar 2021 etwa eine million euro von
einem geldtransporter auf dem
kurfürstendamm gestohlen worden waren
beteiligt gewesen zu sein naja und dann
zu guter letzt noch dieser einzelfall im
november 2020 wurden bei einer razzia
mit über 1600 polizisten drei remo clan
mitglieder festgenommen zwei weitere
wurden zur internationalen fahndung
ausgeschrieben
die staatsanwaltschaft teilte mit dass
ihnen schwerer bandendiebstahl und
brandstiftung in zwei fällen vorgeworfen
werde sie sollen im jahr 2019 in das
grüne gewölbe in dresden eingebrochen
sein und kunstobjekte und juwelen
gestohlen haben im dezember 2020 und
2021 waren schließlich beide
zwillingsbrüder in berlin gefasst worden
die juwelen blieben bisher verschwunden
und werden vermutlich auch nicht mehr
auftauchen
was lässt die besucher reist sein sie
kürte berater michael kuhr denkt sich
seinen teil dazu wir haben die besten
anwälte der stadt aber trotzdem muss
hier einhalt geboten werden und man muss
hart bestrafen wenn die beweislast enorm
an drückend dass da muss ich auch die
gesetze ausreichen oder muss gesetze
auch ändern dass die richter dazu
gezwungen werden bestimmte urteile zu
sprechen und auch jeder lenkte
strafverteidiger burkhard benecken ein
es gibt natürlich auch einige kriminelle
mitglieder in diesen großfamilien und
war einigen gilt es auch als cool wenn
man kriminell ist wenn man sich sein
einkommen auf dem illegalen weg verbot
nach meinem eindruck sind das aber nur
die wenigsten
der großteil die ich jedenfalls kennen
geht einer geregelten beschäftigung nach
acht und muss natürlich unheimlich
darunter leiden was einige wenige
schwarze schafe aus diesen familien
machen und dass sie dann einen ganzen
familie nahmen regelrecht in den dreck
und das ist genau das was ich den medien
aber auch der politik vorwerfen es wird
unheimlich viel vermutet es wird
unheimlich viel unterstellt die
unterstellungen kommen aber nicht von
ungefähr wenn leute wie arafat abou
chaker mit dem lamborghini durch berlin
brettern und das ganze dann prahlerisch
live streamen mächtig stolz auf 150
kilometer pro stunde hin der 30er zone
da kann
[Musik]
ich teste gerade ist
das verstößt
das lässt
[Musik]
wir erleben die situation dass das
verhalten dieser großfamilien dieses
laut truppen draußen runterfahren schaut
mal ich kann die regeln verletzten ohne
dass man etwas passiert schaut mal das
ist unsere straße der deutsche staat hat
hier nichts zu sagen dass diese
mentalität die dort verkörpert wird nach
außen getragen wird den rechtsstaat auf
sylt weil deutlich wird da missachtet
die band unsere regeln und der staat
lässt es zu dass sie regeln missachtet
burkhard benecken strafverteidiger aus
berlin hält dagegen durch seine streiche
sind kindsköpfe eben aber fatal denn den
medien immer als der ganz große
clan-chef dargestellt wird denn ich
darauf hinweise dass dieser mann bisher
völlig unvorbereitet es gibt keine
rechtskräftige vorstrafe dann staunen
viele weil man ihn ja gerne im bereich
der organisierten kriminalität einordnet
nun ja aber es laufen schon einige
verfahren im gleichen livestream
übrigens wedelt arafat abou chaker mit
einem baseball-schläger herum nur so zum
spaß natürlich
[Musik]
andere klein mitglieder machen keine
späße sie schlagen und treten auf einen
am boden liegenden mann einer anderen
familie ein der sich nicht wehrt jemand
filmt es und stellte stolz ins netz das
ist auch für die großfamilie natürlich
alles andere als schön wenn es videos
gibt die dann der öffentlichkeit gezeigt
werden wo einige mit ihrer mitglieder
wirklich schlimme gewaltstraftaten
beginnen da werden menschen grundlos
zusammengeschlagen
zusammengeprügelt aus wirklich nichtigem
anlass und damit spielt man natürlich
den leuten im prinzip argumente so die
dieses über toleranz politik befürworten
und das sehen auch die überwiegende
mitglieder der arabischen großfamilien
sehr sehr kritisch dass es mitglieder
gibt die so etwas machen geschädigte
gehen aus angst oft nicht vor gericht
der zwist spielt dann weiter so beruft
man den friedensrichter ein um eine
eventuelle eskalation zwischen den clan
familien zu stoppen das nennt man
parallel schlichtung der friedensrichter
ist eine übergeordnete respektsperson
der clans er hört sich dann die
vorgetragene problematik an wägt ab und
entscheidet gerade den stammesgebieten
regionen des nahen ostens im libanon und
syrien ist das seit jahrhunderten gang
und gäbe einfach mangels anderer
institutionen in deutschland gibt es
aber eine unabhängige justiz
interessiert die clans aber nicht anwalt
bernhard benecken wäre dann arbeitslos
wenn sich das durchsetzen würde es gibt
in der tat in den arabischen
großfamilien aus den sogenannten
friedensrichter und er ist in der tat da
um frieden zu stiften insbesondere wenn
zb streit zwischen zwei clans vorkommt
ich habe selbst zwei dieser
verhandlungen mit bekommen weil ich eine
familie dazu gebeten hat das war sehr
außergewöhnlich normalerweise lässt man
dort keinen hinzu kommen es war ein über
hundert personen anwesend und am ende
ein rat aus drei älteren herren recht
gesprochen und in dem fall eine schwere
gewalt straftat befriedet durch eine
zahlung von 200.000 euro was ganz
lukrativ klingt untergräbt aber
grundsätzlich unsere demokratische
grundordnung weil es bedeutet dass man
mit gewalt und geld immer durchkommt und
das ist es was wir der organisierten
kriminalität nicht gestatten dürfen
niemals
falko liecke dem stellvertretenden
bezirksbürgermeister von neukölln
demokratisch gewählt und legitimiert
gebührt das letzte wort
ich sage schon mal danke an alle die
zugehört haben und bis zum nächsten mal
bei tatort deutschland die crime doku
von bild
scardino sie akzeptieren unser system
nicht unser rechts und wertesystem sie
machen sich den staat zur beute und das
können wir nicht länger hinnehmen
tatort deutschland die crime doku von
bild produziert von den wakeboard
studios projektleitung lutz neumann und
simone terbrack produktion fabian
schaeffler und felix stäblein
bildredaktion christina frank schneider
und stefan netze wagen sprecher skyteam